hello and welcome to hot take the show
where i take a controversial stance and
explain myself as if i was being
interrogated so lately i've been going
through the dragon ball films per your
recommendations some have been pretty
good and others have made me want to
question my choice of career today i've
decided i hate myself enough to watch
the four films recommended the least aka
the worst dragon ball films as chosen or
not chosen by you those are the third
broly movie biobroly curse of the blood
ruby's the very first dragon ball film
sleeping princess and devil's castle the
second dragon ball film and
dragon ball evolution which
if you'd believe it got the same number
of votes as blood rubies and sleeping
princess one vote they each got one
singular vote so let's start with the
most popular of the worst biobroly after
having spent the last few days in norway
on vacation nothing is a greater slap
back to reality than watching biobroly
okay
let's go there the biobroly is easily
one of the strangest films i have ever
seen and that's saying something when
you consider the subject is dragon ball
with weird slapstick and an even weirder
plot biobroly is the only dragon ball
film that doesn't feature goku at all
oh wait it follows goten trunks and
android 18 as they attempt to pick up
the money mr satan owes them for
throwing the tournament but something
interrupts this a very strange man with
an equally strange entrance issues a
challenge to mr satan with motivations
for doing so being equally as childish
and shallow as the original broly film
i'm sensing a trend having been
requested to fight bio warriors mr satan
18 and the two young saiyans make their
way to the headquarters that is
essentially the entire plot to the film
and it brings us up to about eight
minutes worth of run time how long does
the film get oh yeah 46 minutes the
mastermind behind all of this looks
utterly ridiculous and honestly so do
the bio warriors themselves looking more
like putty monsters from the original
power rangers series than actual real
life threats but let's look at some of
the positives huh it is refreshing
getting to see more of android 18 and mr
satan and in places the action is quite
fun most of the comedic moments do fall
flat on their face for me but there are
certain things here and there involving
mr satan that made me giggle okay that's
literally everything i liked in this
movie and pretty much hated everything
else broly's design was probably his
greatest quality in the first film
however in this film they have done away
with any expression and form he once had
in lieu of an animator's nightmare goo
monster it looks utterly ridiculous and
is the main force of antagonism for the
remainder of the film however this
film's greatest sin is the absolute
worst sin any film can have for me it is
so damn boring the film drags its
bioengineered feet from story beat to
story beat but laboring every single
piece of exposition without getting to
the action until we're over half ways
through the feature and the action in
that latter half is so gross to look at
with bio broly lumbering around like a
dung covered sasquatch that it was
honestly a struggle to get through this
entire film this is easily at the bottom
of my list as the worst of these films
i've seen so far and that's pretty much
everything i have to say about biobroly
now on to the one vote club starting
with dragon ball the legend of shenlang
or curse of the blood rubies if you're
looking at the dub and i'm just going to
say it right from the beginning here
this is much better than the votes gave
it credit for but path to power did this
much better as the very first of the now
numerous dragon ball film library this
movie is largely a retreading of the
pilaf saga with pilaf swapped out for a
brand new villain design a brand new
design that is honestly kinda terrible
the movie employs a very classic style
and honestly doesn't age too well in my
opinion there are tons of static scenes
with little to no movement whatsoever
and with its shorter run time of just 50
minutes it spends way too long retracing
the steps of the show and manga in a
much less appealing way might i add all
the while path the power achieved
fantastic success in both of these areas
with that said like paths to power
there's still tons to sink your teeth
into with the variations in the story
and the characters interactions the
classic feel is still very present in
this film if that's something you enjoy
and there's a nice action sequence with
yamcha too that keeps the film from
being too boring during the midpoint
lull with that said the connecting
threads and quote new stuff this film
brings to the table comes in the form of
this little red-headed girl called pansy
who requires the help of goku and the
others to protect her village from the
main villain of the film king gurumez
and he's not interesting at all and if
i'm being completely honest i don't
really care for this film's story
whatsoever mostly because this is a film
that is largely based on the original
material and because path to power had a
much larger pool to draw from curse of
the blood rubies in comparison with the
scene that they chose to introduce are
much less well known and honestly don't
connect all that well at all
additionally a common complaint i've had
with these films has been how they felt
like extended episodes of the show and
thanks to wikipedia i now know why
apparently these films were all designed
such that they represent what the show
currently has to offer visually and
thematically shown across japan at fairs
and festivals to promote the anime and
manga early on these films took the form
of arc recaps like the pilaf saga and
later became spin-offs like cooler's
revenge and fusion reborn stories
inspired and visually similar to the
story being told at that time in the
manga funnily enough these films have
more in common with dragon ball heroes
than they do with battle of gods
resurrection f and the latest broly film
in 2018. and with all that said curse
the blood rubies i didn't really like
this all too much its story is a little
flat convenient and rushed while not
offering much of value at all fingers
crossed our next film does more speaking
of which sleeping princess is tied with
dragon ball evolution with the same
number of votes that being one whether
evolutions was a meme vote or not
doesn't much matter because the only
person voting for sleeping princess was
my editor so this one is about 40
minutes long deep breaths
let's do that
next up is sleeping princess in devil's
castle alrighty so the entire movie is
based around master roshi's training or
at least the early stages where both
krillin and goku attempt to find a girl
to convince roshi to train them the only
difference being that he specifically
asks for someone in particular the
sleeping princess in devil's castle
and that's basically it the story
chronicles how both goku and krillin
tackle his castle and ultimately save
the princess while featuring all of the
regular cast you come to know and love
some of the humor in the race to get to
the castle is fun and the simple plot
really helped this during its short run
time there was one moment in particular
that legitimately made me laugh out loud
when i saw it check it out
straight up i wasn't expecting that
reaction from bulma and it's gotten a
bigger laugh out of me than pretty much
anything the other films has gotten i
should also mention at this time that
bulma as well as the rest of the crew in
their attempt to reach goku managed to
get themselves wrapped up in the castle
situation strangely enough during this
section with goku and krillin exploring
the creepy surroundings it reminded me a
lot of their episode in dragon ball
super where they explored the forest
which as it happens was another fetch
quest issued by roshi amidst the chaos
of the castle launch shows up guns are
blazing and it's honestly really cool to
be perfectly honest i love launch's
design as the blonde version and seeing
her is always a treat turns out she's
just there to collect the diamond which
happens to be the sleeping princess but
all goes downhill from here as launch
sneezes our heroes all get captured by
the villain lucifer yes that's his name
and his evil plan is about to come to
fruition however he didn't bank on one
thing
goku transforming into the uzaru through
the combined efforts of goku and the
rest of the party they all escape
unharmed bringing back launch to meet
master roshi the end honestly this is
exactly the sort of movie i wanted from
early dragon ball there's tons of new
material and it only utilizes plot
points from the manga to set the stage
in a very bare bone sort of way the
villain is fun the adventure is
captivating and the action is so
distinctly old school dragon ball i very
much enjoyed this movie and now finally
dragon ball evolution from 2009. unlike
the vast majority of these dragon ball
films i've rewatched on this channel
evolution was one i actually saw in
theaters day one it was released around
the time i had stopped watching dragon
ball entirely but i was nevertheless
excited to see my favorite characters on
the big screen in order to go see this i
had to convince my family including my
mother and brothers who had no interest
in seeing this film to go with me as i
honestly had no one else to go with so
we made it a family day out so to speak
i still remember the feeling of
embarrassment and confusion i had
leaving the theater that day trying to
convince myself that it wasn't that bad
but let me tell you
it's that bad and a whole lot more
literally nothing in this film works
from the cgi to the choreography to the
casting to the god-awful script this
film was written as though my mother
wrote it we are talking about a script
so fundamentally broken that the writer
of that script issued a public apology
years later stating that he just needed
the money this is a film featuring
characters that are only like the
originals by name and nothing else this
is a film that had help offered by the
license holders including akira toriyama
himself and denied the option this is
the film that inspired akira toriyama to
make battle of gods and start the modern
generation of dragon ball so i guess
something good came out of this mess of
a film a film that even if i was to take
a look at it as its own standalone thing
not taking inspiration from anything is
still a tone-deaf nonsensical amateurish
teen martial arts movie that has no idea
what it actually wants to be what it
wants to say and plays as if it's
embarrassed of what it is this is by far
the single worst most disappointing film
i have ever seen in my life and i refuse
to watch it again and so it's conclusion
time with all the films i've seen over
the last month or so this is what my
rankings of these films looks like right
now at number one as the best dragon
ball film i've seen is path to power
number two is fusion reborn number three
wrath of the dragon number four sleeping
princess in devil's castle was
surprisingly good number five the
world's strongest number six broly the
legendary super saiyan number seven
coolers revenge number eight bojack
unbound number nine curse of the blood
rubies number ten dead zone number
eleven is biobroly and at a distant
number 12 by far the worst dragon ball
evolution now looking at this at first
glance you might be led to believe that
a large chunk of these are actually
pretty good movies but if i'm being
completely honest apart from path to
power and fusion reborn the other films
i've seen have had moments where i had
fun sure but in general didn't offer
enough for me to care to watch them ever
again and when you drop below the fifth
spot on this list there's just awful
film after awful film in my opinion but
that'll do it for this week subscribe
for more if you want to see it and i'll
see you all next week thank you so much
for watching
[Music]